the end of an era in aviation as the
final Boeing 747 to be built was
delivered to Freight carrier Atlas
airlines
sharing a deep admiration for today's
guest of honor the awe-inspiring Queen
of the Skies
Boeing through a Gala ceremony for the
occasion but it's a Melancholy moment
for Aviation aficionados I don't think
there's really anything quite as iconic
as the 747 and I think anybody who's a
fan of Aviation and has any kind of Soul
it can't help but shed a tear for this
uh rather sad if inevitable moment and
as it slowly begins to roll when the 747
made its made in Flight in 1969 the
aircraft size Sleek design and highly
advanced technology amazed Travelers for
those who could afford it the upper deck
was an Airborne island of luxury and
free champagne the upper deck was a
thing of beauty could you still access
through that that staircase and feel
like you were in your own private Lounge
but it wasn't just a jet for the Jet Set
before the 7 747 long distance air
travel was unaffordable for most people
the new aircraft's range and capacity
changed all that the engines were the
first High bypass commercial engines in
service which meant their economics were
so much better than previous generations
of engines and that really helped get
ticket prices down over the years the
747 carried some historic passengers
including
Ayatollah khomeini's returned to Iran
from Exile in 1979.
and the NASA space shuttle piggybacked
aboard a specially modified 747 an
unforgettable sight in the sky
since 1990 the 747 has been the official
plane of U.S presidents Air Force One
the aircraft was also involved in
aviation history's deadliest disaster
in 1977 two 747s collided on the runway
of an airport on the Spanish island of
Tenerife
583 people were killed
advances in engine technology and
development of lighter weight materials
eventually caused most Airlines to shift
from larger aircraft like the 747 to
smaller more economical two-engine Jets
like the Airbus 320 and Boeing 737
the remaining passenger models of the
747 will be phased out over the next
decade Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera